so let's continue to get caught up about
the aftermath of Donald Trump wondering
aloud about injecting bleach and
isopropyl alcohol as a possible
treatment for coronavirus he said it he
floated the idea that it was sarcasm
that failed so Friday he left the press
briefing without taking a single
question we then learned he would be
reducing the brunt number and duration
of press briefings but more importantly
Trump spent the entire weekend rage
tweeting attacks on media for all of
this and that's the move you you he
tried claiming it was sarcasm and that
failed he you know denying that he ever
said it has obviously failed since we
have cameras in 2020 and we can record
things so Trump spent the whole weekend
with dozens of tweets including some
that he is deleted out of shame
attacking the media for all of this once
again another of Trump's authoritarian
totalitarian tendencies attack the press
constantly for everything while never
taking responsibility so let's take a
look at or through Trump's weekend rage
tweeting starting with lies about virus
testing Trump saying many testing sites
are and have been open and available
just past five million tests far more
than any other country in the world in
fact more than all other major countries
combined don't believe the fake news now
that's just a short statement but it's
riddled with lies first of all what
matters is testing per capita we are
forty first and testing per capita the
total number of tests doesn't matter
that much but also remember that the
Trump administration promised that we
would have done more than twenty million
tests by the end of March it's the end
of April and we've done only five
million but Trump insists it's the media
that is lying to you know he's the one
lying to you then going into bleach
injection saying quote was just informed
that the fake news from the Thursday
White House press conference had me
speaking and asking questions of dr.
Burks wrong I was speaking to our
laboratory expert not Deborah about
sunlight etc and the coronavirus the
lamestream media is corrupt and sick now
of course the video is very clear Trump
turns to her and literally says Debora
have you heard of injecting heat and
light and she says well there is
this thing called fever so again it's
another lie but a pointless lie it's
neither here nor there
in Trump wondering aloud about bleach
and isopropyl injections then maybe
Trump's key tweet of the weekend now
defending why he won't be doing press
briefings of course the real reason he's
gonna pare them down is it's become an
embarrassment he says it's because of
the media tweeting quote what is the
purpose of having White House news
conferences when the lamestream media
asks nothing but hostile questions and
then refuses to report the truth or
facts accurately they get record ratings
and the American people get nothing but
fake news not worth the time and effort
he said something that is the source of
international shame for the United
States that's why he's being advised to
pare down the meetings but he attacks
the media as the reason and
unfortunately it probably works with
many of his followers another media
attack remember this is the president in
the midst of a pandemic spending his
entire weekend tweeting stuff like this
saying quote I never said the pandemics
was a hoax who would do such a thing I
said that the do-nothing Democrats
together with their mainstream media
partners are the hoax they have been
called out and embarrassed on this even
admitting they were wrong but continue
to spread the lie remember it's Trump
who's been called out and embarrassed
internationally for saying what about
injecting bleach and of course he did
refer to it as a hoax many times then
amid numerous well sourced reports that
Trump has recently been watching five to
seven hours of news every morning before
strolling into work at noon Trump says
quote the people that know me and know
the history of our country say that I am
the hardest-working president in history
I don't know about that but I am a hard
worker and have probably gotten more
done in the first three and a half years
than any president in history the fake
news hates it that one obviously alive
but we don't really need to debunk it
and then this is the cherry on top a
three tweet gong show where he said and
subsequently deleted because of the
embarrassing misspelled
when will all of the reporters who have
received Nobel Prizes and I'm saying not
Nobel noble and Oh ble Nobel Prizes for
their work on Russia Russia Russia only
to have been proven totally wrong and in
fact it was the other side who committed
the crimes be turning back their
cherished nobles again an o BL es so
that they can be given to the real
reporters and journalists who got it
right I can give the committee a very
comprehensive list
when will the Nobel Committee demand the
prizes back that this is one sentence
folks especially since they were gotten
under fraud the reporters and lamestream
media knew the truth all along lawsuits
should be brought against all including
the fake news organizations that's
capital F capital and capital o to
rectify this terrible injustice for all
of the great lawyers out there do they
have any takers
when will the Nobel Committee Act that's
a capital A on Act better be fast those
were deleted I assume because of Nobel
vs Nobel but also maybe because it is
the adjutant other kind of medication to
be tweeting out not the President of the
United States in the middle of a Sunday
afternoon an entire weekend after a
globally embarrassing debacle attacking
media and press as the source of his
problems this is not a well man we're
gonna do a deep dive later in the week
about how this has become a sort of last
straw for a lot of people around the
world to realize that this man is
fundamentally unwell but what matters
here in the u.s. is whether our voters
realize it people in Germany realizing
Trump is sick doesn't really help remove
them in November if Americans who don't
vote realize Trump is sick it also
doesn't help remove him in November
people who are going to vote or who can
be convinced to vote they are the ones
who need to realize it and I don't know
that they are one of our sponsors is
privacy calm they're giving you five
dollars when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy calm
slash Pakman I've been using privacy for
a little over
year now you've heard me talk about it
before it's a lifesaver and here's how
it works takes just a couple of minutes
to set up anytime you buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app and the browser
plugin let you give each company a
randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click and the payment is taken out of
your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them any time you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm / Pakman